الخميس أو الجمعة هو الموعد المتوقع
لتسليم الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب نفسه إلى
سجن مقاطعة فولتون، وذلك وفقًا
لمصدر رفيع المستوى في إنفاذ القانون على
علم بهذا الاستسلام، ويوم الجمعة
بالطبع يمثل الموعد النهائي لـ DA
fawnee Willis عندما يكون جميع الـ 19 شخصًا
يجب على المتهمين تسليم أنفسهم الآن، تقول مصادر لشبكة
CNN إن فريق ترامب كان
على اتصال بالفعل بمكتب المدعي العام،
وستستمر هذه المحادثات حتى
الأسبوع المقبل على وجه التحديد بشأن ظروف
مثوله وأيضًا بشأن لوجستيات
استسلامه، ونحن نعلم الآن أن
المسؤولين، بما في ذلك
أصر عمدة مقاطعة فولتون، بات لابونتي، على أن
ترامب والمتهمين الآخرين
سيتم معاملتهم مثل أي شخص آخر على
وجه التحديد من خلال أخذ بصمات الأصابع والصور الفوتوغرافية،
ولكن من المحتمل أن يكون ذلك مستحيلًا فقط
بسبب الاحتياطات الأمنية التي
يجب اتخاذها عندما يتعلق الأمر
بنقل أ  الرئيس السابق
للولايات المتحدة وكذلك
الطبيعة البارزة لبعض هؤلاء
المتهمين الآخرين، لذا فمن المحتمل جدًا أن
عملية الحجز هذه، التي عادةً ما
تستغرق ساعات من الانتظار، من
المحتمل أن تتم بسرعة أكبر بالنسبة
لترامب وبعض من أتباعه.  من
الممكن أيضًا أن يتطلع المتهمون المشاركون إلى
الاستدعاء في أول ظهور لهم في
المحكمة، ومن الممكن ألا يضطروا
حتى إلى المثول أمام المحكمة لأن
القاضي هنا يمكن أن يختار القيام بهذا
الاستدعاء افتراضيًا أو السماح لهم
بالتنازل عن هذا الحق في الاستدعاء
تقرير من خارج سجن مقاطعة فولتون،
إيزابيل روزاليس، سي إن إن